Tiger Williams is a film and TV writer
adjunct professor at the USC School of
Cinematic Arts the UCLA School of
Theatre film television and a creative
advisor with the Sundance Institute
screenwriters lab his credits include
menace to society the perfect guy and
the upcoming Netflix series madam CJ
Walker he is currently a writer on the
FX series snowfall presenting the award
turn a Palais is Tiger Williams the
bickering the bantering the fussing the
fighting the little boy who's not
talking you know you you you read it and
you get into it Nick where am I headed
what is this and I have to say yes you
made me cry
Rene healthful Malaysia and which was
notified that she wanted Nikhil
you know she applied for her first
passport and you know but she also
needed a US visa but the earliest
interview they could get was on November
8th but with the help of our amazing
nickel staff meeting was arranged with
the Cultural Affairs Office at the US
Embassy in Malaysia and they agreed to
craft an appeal to the Consul General
and it was expedite the thing and Rene's
friends got together and it pulls some
money and she hopped in the car and
drove two hours to kuala lumpur to the
embassy and we're happy to have her here
[Applause]
you know at first glance you know boy
with kite it's a it's a simple story
about a woman and a man and a you know
and a boy that ends this this family and
ultimately illuminates their lives but
it's it's much more than a simple story
it's complex it's as complexes as life
is it's a very human and universal story
and it's not about it's not about a
woman it's not about it's not about
Malaysia it's not about the things that
often as particular genders or people of
color are expected to write it it
touches all of us we know all of these
characters we are all of these
characters I came away from the script
caring deeply about these characters and
their lives and as I said she brought a
tear to my eye and in a time when movies
are increasingly becoming technological
marvels not Marvel technological marvels
I believe the ability to infuse real
emotion into our work is a skill that's
more valuable than ever and I value
[Laughter]
Wow
Thank You mr. Williams I had no idea
there was a Salazar if you were like
4050 years older but you're not it was
amazing
hearing all it's amazing just being here
because you've heard the story of my
journey and on that front I have to I
have a whole bunch of thank-yous I'm so
sorry to subject all of you to this but
I'll make it very fast thank you to
Sangha Billy Irvin hail Julianne Lee
Jenny Christy Lau Zoe Elena
Molina Kasturi cassavan as Lina Muhammad
Youssef some of them gave me money when
times were bad all of them gave me food
and shelter when times were really bad
and they never once told me stop writing
but I I wouldn't blame them if they did
fact is I've never taken a writing class
I come from 14,000 miles away I don't
even speak English half the time and I
want to write movies here in Hollywood
what kind of fool thinks that is
possible
but more importantly the reason for this
is because when you come from the place
where your writings not understood not
encouraged when there's no room for the
stories you have to tell when you're not
given the space to exist then even
though these are dark times here it's
dark times all over the world and
Hollywood starts to look about Hollywood
starts to make sense and that's a bit
scary isn't it and the sense that it
makes is that there are freedoms here
freedoms that so many of us take for
granted
for example the freedom to write about
exotic places like Nebraska
the freedom to write about people who
are nothing like you but who are you the
freedom to connect with others
irrespective of whoever whatever
wherever you are because like Ben that
little boy who doesn't speak can speak I
suspect all of us like me I wanted to be
heard I think we all want to be heard
and that's why all this work all of this
by Joan and and Chris and the whole
Nicholl fellowship team it's work that's
not only important it's necessary
because if not voices like Stella and
Lenny and Ben and mine would never be
heard because if it wasn't for them the
Academy and the nickel committee none of
people like me we wouldn't get a chance
to be heard and I realize now after
meeting the nickel committee yesterday
it's because every single one of these
people I always want to say this well
frankly my dear they do give a damn they
totally do
so now what I get from all this is
moving forward when ever I'm I'm gonna
be told that I'm all wrong when I'm not
given the room to exist or the freedom
to be then I'll remember that
improbabilities well they can happen I
am one of them they can be so many more
thank you